ja willkommen zur letzten Sendung im
Rahmen des Seminars Philosophie der
Aufklärung heute geht es zum Abschluss
über das Thema digitale Aufklärung was
ist digitale Aufklärung wir werden dazu
ein Blick auf das Phänomen der digitalen
Enzyklopädien wie zum Beispiel Wikipedia
werfen und es auch Rück beziehen auf
unsere Diskussion der gedruckten
Enzyklopädien hier am Beispiel der
Enzyklopädie von Dieter mache ich oben
rechts den Link zu dieser Sendung hinein
das soll im Zentrum stehen wir haben ein
paar Leitfragen worin unterscheidet sich
die digitale Aufklärung von der analogen
traditionellen Wohnmobil die besteht die
Gefahr einer digitalen Unmündigkeit wie
können wir der digitalen Unmündigkeit
entgehen inwiefern können wir Wikipedia
als moderne Enzyklopädie der Aufklärung
verstehen das sind die Fragen hier gibt
es ein interessantes meme was dieses
Phänomen Wikipedia sehr treffend
charakterisiert got to wikipedia Check
think of fact unten realized free hours
Leder that you know everything about the
Sowjetunion das heißt hier sieht man
schon die
verweisungstruktur die Verlinkung die
hypertextuelle Verlinkung innerhalb
dieser Entwicklung die eine eigene
Dynamik entwickelt Frage ist ist die so
neu es gibt ein Gedicht von Eugen rot
was schon viel älter ist mit dem Titel
das Hilfsbuch ein Mensch nichts wissen
von Mormone schaut deshalb nach im
lexikonen und hättest dort auch rasch
gefunden jedoch er weiß nach drei vier
Stunden von den Hormonen keine Silbe
dafür fast alles von der Milbe von
Mississippi nur und Maus im ganzen m
kennt er sich aus das ist dasselbe
Phänomen vielleicht jetzt nicht direkt
so wegen Verlinkungen aber wenn man ein
Lexikon hat und die Organisation der
Wissensordnung sich anschaut dann kann
es schon passieren dass man am Ende wo
ganz anders auskommt
die traditionelle Enzyklopädie versucht
das Wissen zu organisieren nach
bestimmten Kriterien dieser Wissensbaum
wo man jetzt auch mal rein Zoomen hier
diesen unteren Teil an diesen standteil
die versucht jetzt das Wissen
zurückzuführen auf unsere Erkenntnis
theoretischen Vermögen Erinnerungen das
sind die Geschichtswissenschaften mit
verbunden Verstand damit ist die
Philosophie verbunden und die
Einbildungskraft die Vorstellung damit
sind die Künste verbunden so kann man
natürlich wissen organisieren dass man
es auf unsere Vermögen zurückführt
gibt es noch eine andere Darstellung
dieses System der Wissens der
Enzyklopädie hier kann man auch schauen
wieder die Erinnerung des Gedächtnis die
Vernunft und die einwillungskraft
ich hatte schon mal darauf hingewiesen
dass die Verweise ganz wichtig sind in
der Enzyklopädie in der ausseegruppe die
das sieht man einem Artikel
Menschenfresser anthropophag hier unten
gibt es ein Verweis auf die Eucharistie
was man gar nicht vermuten mag das ist
aber gerade die
revolutionäre Leistung der Musikgruppe
die nicht so sehr über den eigentlichen
Text
anzuregen zum Denken oder auch zu
provozieren sondern über die Verweise wo
man eben dann selbst sich seinen Teil
dabei denken muss die Verweise nehmen
eigentlich das Denken ab wie kalt gesagt
hatte dass es die Bücher tun können wenn
ich nur ein Buch habe dann weiß ich ja
alles sondern die Verweise in der
Entwicklung die die die
ermuntern uns aufgeklärt zu denken und
insofern reflektieren diese Artikel in
manchen verweisen jedenfalls bereits
diese Problematik der Medialität und der
Unendlichkeit das hat natürlich damals
für Aufsehen gesorgt das war damals
natürlich unerhört eine Provokation die
ganz bewusst zu eingeplant worden war
ja jetzt kann man sich fragen worin
besteht eigentlich die digitale
Unmündigkeit Manfred Spitzer hat hier
ein paar Bücher geschrieben die
naheliegend dass darin die Unnötigkeit
bestehen könnte digitale Demenz wir
spielen nur Computer wie diese Bilder
hier nahezulegen scheinen cyberkrank wir
sind nur im Internet und dass
digitalisierte Leben ruiniert unsere
Gesundheit oder wir haben nur
Smartphones um uns herum und schauen die
ganze Zeit drauf und werden deswegen
davon infiziert eines Smartphone
Epidemie so kann man natürlich
Digitalisierung im Geiste der Aufklärung
versuchen zu kritisieren allerdings
greift diese Kritik wie ich meine zu
kurz weil hier nur ein falscher Medien
gebrauchte Digitalisierung kritisiert
wird und der richtige gebrauchte
digitalen Medien der aufgeklärte
gebraucht überhaupt nicht diskutiert
wird ja jetzt hier noch Jürgen habermaß
etwas dazu gesagt zu Jürgen abermaßen
mache ich oben rechts den Link rein zur
letzten Sendung er hat gesagt dass er
sich bei exklusiven Nutzern sozialer
Medien er denkt natürlich an Facebook
und so weiter sich eine Weise der halb
öffentlichen fragmentierten und in sich
kreisenden Kommunikation durchgesetzt
hat er sieht das für etwas
Problematisches an weil es unsere
meinungs- und Willensbildung gefährdet
ja hier spricht ihr noch mal ein
bisschen genauer davon also die
gehorchen diese sozialen Plattform nur
den Imperativen der Kapitalverwertung
also es geht letztendlich nur um nutzen
Gewinnmaximierung und das kann natürlich
für den öffentlichen Diskurs den
aufgeklärten Diskurs nicht gut sein
es gibt ein weiteres Buch mit dem
titelfilter Bubble wie wir im Internet
entmündigt werden das ist auch der
Hinweis auf eine Form von digitaler
Unmöglichkeit wenn wir uns in einer
Förderband befinden kriegen wir
Suchergebnisse auf uns zugeschnitten
kommerziell interessiert so dass hier
auch keine Objektivität vorliegt glauben
wir bequem objektive Ergebnisse zum
Beispiel von Google angezeigt aber im
Grunde genommen sind das kommerziell
Interessierte auf uns zugeschnittene
werbemäßig orientierte Ergebnisse das
ist keine Objektivität das ist eine Form
der digitalen Unmöglichkeiten ja genauso
kann man eine Form von digitale
Unmündigkeit darin erblicken wenn wir
nur wie aprillen aufhaben wie hier in
der platonischen Höhle in dem neuen Buch
von David als auch virtuelle Realität
verstanden nur als Simulation als
weltflug kann eine Form von digitaler
Aufklärung nicht sein sondern nur
digitaler Unmöglichkeit ja
hier gibt's ein paar Punkte zu digitalen
Unmöglichkeit wir werden nur
Datenmaterial digitales wie für die
großen sozialen Plattformen die halten
uns nur informationsblasen auf verwenden
die Digitalisierung technokratisch oder
nur zum Sinn der bloßen Simulation wie
in diesem vorherigen Bild im
platonischen höhlengleichnisses 21
jahrhunderts das kann man es auch weiter
sich genauer anschauen das wollen wir
jetzt hier aber nicht tun worin besteht
jetzt der Ausgang aus der digitalen
Unmündigkeit wir sollten natürlich diese
Medien nicht nur die digitalen als
Unterhaltungsmedien gebrauchen sondern
wir sollten Sie kreativ nutzen um unsere
Freiheit zu vergrößern genau genommen
unseren öffentlichen digitalen Gebrauch
der Vernunft wie man im Anschluss an
kann sagen könnte zu Kant mache ich auch
oben rechts noch mal ein Link rein
genauso sollten wir virtuelle Realität
nicht nur als Simulation verstehen
sondern als öffentlichen Gebrauch der
Vernunft das Internet ist auch nicht
nach der Digital aufgeklärten
Einstellung ein bloßes konsummedium
sondern ein Freiheitsraum der uns unsere
Grund gibt Bedürfnis nach Freiheit
entgegenkommt
es geht also darum unseren Vernunft
gebraucht zu erweitern zu öffentlich
anzulegen und dazu die digitalen Medien
zu gebrauchen das ist der aufgeklärte
gebrauchte digitalen Vernunft
ja wir eröffnen Handlungsräume wir
ermöglichen Partizipationen durch die
Digitalisierung flexibel Mitbestimmung
demokratische Mitbestimmung wir machen
uns frei von Einschränkungen die durch
die analoge Welt gegeben ist wie sieht
es jetzt aus mit dem metabversum dem
Internet man kann jetzt sagen die
neuerentwicklung des Internets hin von
vip1.02 für 3.0 liegen gerade auf der
Spur eines öffentlichen Gebrauchs der
digitalen Vernunft weil hier Strukturen
entwickelt werden wie z.B die
blockchain-technologie da mache ich auch
oben rechts links zu dem Video rein
gerade diesen öffentlichen Diskurs
ermöglichen der nicht mehr nur
kommerziell interessiert ist weil es an
jedem Individuum hängt und ich an einer
zentral Instanz Facebook mit perversum
ist jedenfalls keinen Fall von Web 3.0
von Metaversum in diesem philosophische
idealen sind weil es auch nur
kommerziell interessiert ist
wir sollten natürlich dazu beitragen
dieses dezentrale nun kommerzielle
Internet zu vergrößern im Sinne der
digitalen Aufklärung wie zum Beispiel
durch Wikipedia wenn wir selbst dort
aktiv werden ja das bringt mich zum
Schluss noch auf Wikipedia wie
unterscheidet sich Wikipedia von der
herkömmlichen auseklopädie wir haben
schon gesehen ist eine andere Raumzeit
und wissenslogik die hier zugrunde liegt
durch die digitale Struktur wir können
den Hyperlinks reibungslos folgen wir
müssen nicht zu einem anderen Band
laufen im Regal wie in der ersten Gruppe
die jetzt kann man sich fragen ist diese
Reibungslosigkeit der digitalen
entwickelt was nur äußerlich ist das
Aktien ist oder betrifft das das Wesen
vielleicht sogar ändert sich digitale
Enzyklopädie wenn es hier reibungsfrei
Verlinkungen geht wir können aber auch
kollaborativ an Artikeln arbeiten und
zwar immer wieder flexibel das war auch
nicht möglich in der aussieht glaube die
wir können die Verweise vernetzen und
wir können Sie auch mit äußeren Inhalten
direkt Verlinken zum Beispiel Bilder
direkt einbeziehen durch die Links das
sind Dinge die sich so in der
traditionellen Ausblicke die nicht
realisieren lesen wir können auch die
diskussive Versionsgeschichte der
jeweiligen Artikel nachvollziehen das
heißt den Diskurs er wirklich
dokumentieren und das ist auch in der
außergruppe die nicht mehr sichtbar
diese ganze Diskussion die im Vorhinein
da stattgefunden hat bis es dann zu
diesem getrunken Artikel kam ja es liegt
also kurz gesagt digital und die Gluten
eine andere Form von Partizipation
zugrunde auch eine andere Form von
Vernunft und digitalen öffentlichen
Vernunft
t ja das war die letzte Sitzung die
letzte Sendung in diesem Seminar
Philosophie der Aufklärung ich bedanke
mich vielmals für die Aufmerksamkeit und
freue mich auf eine der nächsten Folgen
mit den Zuschauern und Zuschauen auf
YouTube